hi I'm TP I'm a software engineer at
Google and I'm here to talk about web
assembly so what is web assembly web
assembly is a portable efficient binary
format so say you have a C C++ a robust
program you can compile it to web
assembly and run it on the web so
there's a couple of interesting things
on the slide the first one that says
that the initial version of web assembly
has reached cross-browser consensus what
this means is that representatives from
different browser vendors like Chrome
Firefox edge WebKit they've all agreed
on what the API surface should look like
and the binary format the other super
exciting thing to me is that web
assembly is being designed in an open
standard in a community group w3c
community group so aside from the fact
that it includes representatives from
all of the major browser vendors there's
also representatives from Intel arm
different companies that are potential
users for web assembly so some of the
things that are awesome about web
assembly are that it's efficient and
fast it's low time efficient in the
sense that it's design as a binary
format so it's fewer bits over the wire
and it's more efficient to load it's
fast because it tries by design web
assembly tries to make use of hardware
capabilities to give it the speed that
it needs so it's safe because it tries
to enforce the same-origin security
policies that are in use in the rest of
the web the other exciting thing about
this is that it's part of the open web
platform in the sense that it can call
in and out of JavaScript it uses the
same API surface that JavaScript uses to
use browser functionality
and I think the important thing to talk
about here is also what webassembly
tries to not be it is not a replacement
for JavaScript by design web assembly is
try web Sam Lee should interoperate well
with JavaScript if you noticed a logo a
hassle is this tiny slot on the top
where the JavaScript logo is supposed to
kind of fit so it's definitely not a
replacement for JavaScript the other
thing to note that it is not a
programming language I guess you could
think of it as a programming language if
you think of assembly as a programming
language as well in the sense that this
is something that the compiler should
generate and not something you should be
writing by hand you can write it by hand
to try it out but to make it efficient
and get it to use all of the
optimizations you want the compiler to
generate this for you it is not a
plug-in in the sense that is internal to
the browser engine so it shares the same
stack the other important thing that you
want to note here is that it's not a
target for dynamic languages yet in the
sense that we have proposals that are
ongoing that you know that we're
exploring to support GCD objects in web
assembly so you can have different
languages that are not limited to a
linear memory model like Steve C++ or
rust so one of the primary motivations
for web assembly is that you want native
code on the web so what is what exactly
is native court and why do we want it so
if you look at applications now there's
more and more complex applications that
you want to port to the web these are
game engines image decoders a whole
variety of compute intensive performance
intensive applications that you want to
port to the web and ideally you would
want these to work at neo native speed
so have the performance that native
applications give you you want it to be
portable
the sense that you want to compile once
and run on different platforms so you
want it to be safe you wanted to run in
a sandboxed execution environment so
those are the things that native code
offers you and three these are some of
the primary motivations for working on
web assembly the other interesting thing
is that you can you have all of this
existing a native code that uses WebGL
different native capabilities that you
can now compile to run on the web one of
the reasons why web assembly is actually
useful is the fact that it's challenging
to use machine capabilities through
JavaScript so if you have threads simply
these are things that easier to use if
you're on a native application but you
have to jump through a whole bunch of
Hoops to actually be able to use any of
this on JavaScript there have been
previous attempts to get native code on
the web one of these was Chrome's
solution which is portable Native Client
this gave you performance security a lot
of native functionality but it was only
supported on Chrome so it wasn't
portable I mean its portable in the
sense that you can run it on different
architectures but it's just it's
specific to Chrome and you can't
possibly run it on Firefox because of
architecture limitations the other
Mozilla's approach to this is Ashley as
andreas so let's talk a little bit more
about Azzam Jas
so as I'm Jas is a subset of JavaScript
that can be optimized and used as a
low-level target for compilers if you
see that program on the right there
so one of the things about javascript is
that it's a dynamically typed language
so the engine has to do a lot of work to
figure out what types exist in your
program and optimize according to those
as in GS gets rid of some of that in the
sense that it uses type annotations for
its parameters and return type so you
can optimize based on that you you can
he give the compiler give the engine a
hint and say okay use as in and this it
would try to use the specific subset of
JavaScript that Adam Jess specifies so
why not just use Azam Jess why do we
want a whole different thing like well
webassembly first off slower startup
that's also known as parsing is
expensive as MJS is a textual format so
textual formats are usually orders of
magnitude slower than binary formats to
powers so that's a it gives you it kind
of hinders speed in that way you also
have limited functionality what do I
mean by this
it's just that well as MJS is still a
subset of JavaScript so you there's a
whole bunch of things that you can't
actually use like 64-bit integers if you
have loads and stores you need to
underline loads and stores you need to
mask them it's again harder to get to
CPU specific features the other thing is
that even though you're kind of giving
the engine a hint that says use Azzam on
a validation failure this falls back to
regular JavaScript so the performance in
this sense can be inconsistent the most
important reason why we cannot use
Azam's yes that is that it's not a
standard so different browsers have
different ways that they optimize Azzam
j/s so you have wedding levels of
performance across browsers so we're at
the node summit why are we talking about
webassembly
so first off note 8 supports web
assembly so node 8 is built on top of we
ate 5.8 which enables web assembly by
default so you kind of get this for free
the other thing is that one of web
assemblies high-level goals is actually
to support non-web embeddings reasonably
well
and web assembly modules can be imported
into a node.js app so you can expose web
assembly functions for use why a
JavaScript so the what are the benefits
of you know having web assembly module
in your app on the backend because web
assembly is a portable IR you can ship a
single binary to any platform in the
sense you build ones and you can ship it
for different platforms the important
thing to note here is that portability
comes with a cost so if you want
portability is there's a chance that
you're making a performance trade-off in
the sense that your native binaries are
always going to be faster I mean with
caveats but your native binaries will be
faster because they can directly go to
the machine code but it's just it's just
something to keep in mind whether you
want portability or whether you want the
same speed another way to think about
this is you know think about your app in
general so you have the client side and
the server side so when client side
applications that things you do like
image compression and language detection
and other things mainly image
compression let's take image compression
as an example this is something that if
your image is large enough you would
want to send to the server but with web
assembly you have you can do this kind
of compression on the client side itself
so you can kind of rethink what goes on
the client side and what goes on the
server so we talked about importing a
web assembly module into your node.js
app so what does the web assembly module
look like so this is a web assembly
module a web assembly module has linear
memory which is a contiguous byte a
durable by byte addressable range of
memory and it can go from like the
offset of zero to whatever dynamic
memory size and whatever memory size and
you can also dynamically resize this
memory a table is similar to a linear
so instead of being bites these are
opaque values of particular table
element type the main use of this in the
web assembly MEP is you use this for
indirect calls other interesting
elements of the module you have Global's
so you store a single value of a fixed
type in a global and that you know it's
it's kind of separate from your linear
memory so it can be arbitrarily access
functions obviously are the most
interesting part of your module because
they have all the code so this is this
is kind of these are the basic building
blocks of a web assembly module so the
web assembly module can also define
imports so a module can declare a
sequence of imports at instantiation
optionally these can be memory table
functions Global's the the main point
here to note is that you can only have
one linear memory and one table right
now in the MVP
you also have exports so a module can
declare a sequence of exports that are
returned to the host environment and
instantiation so with all of this I've
been talking about instantiation so the
instance is the one that has all of the
static state that you need to run a
module so if you look at this like the
imports and the exports are you know
kind of open-ended in the sense of how
you interact with your host environment
so you can import functions that are
defined by the host environment that can
interact with your web assembly module
or you can export functions from your
web assembly module to your host
environment and it's it's kind of
open-ended what you want to do with it
and so we've been talking about
webassembly module what does it look
like so there's two things that have
been defined in the MVP which is the
textual format and the binary format so
the code below is what the disassembly
of a function looks like so if you this
function is just like an arbitrary
function that has some memory operations
and it takes two parameters and it adds
them so if you look at it the first
section is the textual representation of
the function so and you have a
one-to-one mapping at the bottom to the
binary format everything on the Left is
offset so the actual compressed code is
just your so if you look at it it's if
you look at the i30 to add line six a is
the up code for I 30 to add so you can
see how much it's been compressed so
it's just you know a string of bytes
that represent that function so if we
want to take a step back and see what a
module looks like so this is web
assembly module and it's just again it's
a string of bytes everything on the
left-hand side is actually just offset
and you can see what the bytes the bytes
after the colon in the sense the first
colored section there represents the
binary version you have a section that
defines what functions are present so
you have you know you have a function
you're just number of functions this one
you the signature index you also have a
memory section which defines the number
of memories memory index zero what are
what are its limits etc in this case we
have one exported function so the
exported export section also defines
that and the function body is what I've
kind of splayed out there to look at so
how is webassembly implemented in v8
when we look at this this is how your v8
parses JavaScript code so if
I'm sorry p8 the compiler pipeline this
is what the compiler pipeline of we it
looks like kind of glossing over some of
the things there but if you have
JavaScript source code it gets parsed
and you generate these STS and the
JavaScript graphs are then get in line
load and pass to the JavaScript
optimized so so you have it it tries to
figure out what the type information is
and run all of these optimization passes
um so how does web assembly fit into
this picture so what the wasm compiler
does is web assembly all is already
optimized it has static type information
so you just directly feed it into the
Machine graph of which goes to the back
end and it generates machine code
specific to the platforms which could be
on Intel arm mips whatever a native code
you want to generate so there's some
things that I want to point out here
we've been talking about performance
we've been talking about speed some of
the caveats that you should take into
account is performance is really tricky
to measure so based on your bench if you
decided you want to put something over
to web assembly this doesn't mean that
this will make it fast on all your
benchmarks it's it's on a case-to-case
basis it's you know it's just there's a
lot of things that you have to worry
about when you're doing performance
measurement the other thing that is also
important to note is web assembly is an
emerging standard so you know there's
use cases where you assume that web
assembly is fast and in case it's not
you know we have bugs like every pretty
else does and it's something that we're
still working on the other important
thing to note is you have to use the
right language for the job so if you
have computation intensive programs or
CPU intensive programs web assembly
makes a good case for you it makes a
good case for you to use port your
application to web assembly but if you
don't
you know there's cases where JavaScript
does the job right in those cases where
webassembly is the right way to do it
ties into the same thing that
webassembly tackles specific use cases
and it's not a blanket solution to all
your performance problems so what are
some of the use cases that you can use
webassembly for you have encryption
video augmentation game distribution you
have image video editing there's just a
whole bunch of applications a
server-side computation of untrusted
code there's a lot more applications and
use cases that I haven't actually put on
the slide but you kind of get the
general idea there so we're at MVP and
what are some of the post MVP features
that were actually considering so we are
considering threads atomic operators
it's basically to provide low-level
building blocks for pthread style shared
memory you've shared memory between
threads you have Atomics and few taxes
the other thing that we're exploring is
fixed with Cindy we've made efforts to
do this in JavaScript with some DHS but
it's it's been tricky in the sense that
you know it's probably not going to be
as performant in the JavaScript cases
there's not as many use cases but it
fits well into the web assembly use case
there's also exception handling you can
emulate exception handling through
JavaScript but you know it gives you the
correct semantics but it's not going to
be fast so one of the things that's in
progress is sido cast exceptions um so I
talked a little bit earlier about C C++
and rust and you know use these modules
in compile least oh bab assembly so we
want to be able to support different
languages so what do we want to do when
it comes to dynamic languages we're
trying to build
you know built like a garbage collection
mechanism that can efficiently allocate
and manipulate GC objects in ways encode
so contributing like I said earlier with
webassembly one of the high-level goals
is that we want to work well for non web
use cases so you know it's we appreciate
input from different web communities to
see if this actually fits their use case
if it doesn't we would love for you to
come up to us and tell us why it doesn't
work there's a lot of information on a
bassam leader org
including a really cool tanks demo
that's based on the Unity engine there's
also lots of tips and tricks to get
started that the github pages up there
like I said earlier we work as a part of
the w3c community group we have regular
meetings that are over we see and
sometimes in person to discuss use cases
to discuss future features to discuss
implementation like all the kind of
applications that we're trying to cover
so you know if this is something that
interests you we would love for you to
come up to us and tell us how this
doesn't cover your use case and you know
talk about it to the other implementers
as well thanks
[Applause]